president from unloading on Democrats at
a rally ahead of today's pivotal special
election in North Carolina's ninth
congressional district Republican Dan
Bishop is facing off against Democrat
Dan McReady in a race many see as a
preview of 2020 the president urging
voters to back bishop will also slamming
democrats progressive policies watch him
here a vote for any Democrat in 2020 and
a vote for any Democrat tomorrow in
North Carolina is a vote for the rise of
radical socialism and the destruction of
the American dream I wouldn't mind
fighting the Democrats but we really
have to look at is to do some it's the
media and the Democrats it's one and the
same and they tried to do the recession
thing you know they tried the Russia
thing that didn't work they tried
many other things so the president in
his element last night one I just wanna
talk about North Carolina for just a
moment before we go to a couple of other
quick sound bites from the rally which
were incredible and very fun voter fraud
is an issue that led to this special
election special elections usually low
voter turnout you've got North
Carolina's just coming through the
hurricane what do you expect could
happen there we know that North Carolina
is going to be a place that all the
candidates are gonna go Democrats are
gonna try to flip that like Obama did in
2008 but the president is gonna be there
all the time including at his convention
right so that what's interesting to me
is I think the president won this by 12%
it run North Carolina by 12 percentage
points in 26 district and and in this
district is their key point but suddenly
he's there and he's there with some
anxiety one I guess as you pointed out
there was voter fraud in that Mark
Harris campaign or Republicans campaign
and so the you get the the Board of
Elections saying we have to have a redo
that's what we're going through today
and right now the polls show them tied
it's a guys feel pretty good about tying
it they do Dan McReady turns out to be
pretty good candidates pretty young
energetic candidate Dan Bishop the
reason the president's there is he wants
to bolster bishop at a time when you
know with the economy slowing all these
questions you know he doesn't seem to go
kennedy because i think i should say i'm
opining it's not for the president to go
because whether he went down there at
campaign or didn't no matter what the
outcome is everybody was gonna point to
President Trump for the win or the loss
absolutely and you know going there he's
in full election mode this is one of the
swing states as you point out and he
only won the state by four percentage
points and there are a lot of dance in
this race there's a lot of dancing and
Dan McReady the Democrat he wants to
beat the bishop I don't know if he's
going to be able to do that the
Democrats if he comes within two or
three points they will consider that a
victory they will ad can beat to play
this other soundbite sure you don't need
my permission
all right I don't need his permission
but I'd like to ask it because I said I
admire you Jessie but listen to this
this is the president talking about
lights I'm not a vain person I know I
have no vain people especially these are
ladies in the front but I look better
under an incandescent light than these
crazy lights that are beaming down
lighting very critical yes isn't it you
know he knows that he's in teepees from
the TV world yeah I'm not a vain person
the media already fact-checked that we
were just we were just talking about we
both agree we all look better with
incandescent lights yes yeah I guess
they're bad for the environment well but
I mean how bad are they because we
really need to look good you know what
we've done we've done some great a great
job of innovating so that you have more
efficient lighting and it's also less
expensive and also we can still look
good yes but we don't like to be told
and that's why this is a good issue for
him he's saying the government is
telling you you can't have your old
light bulbs so even people who don't
have a preference they don't like the
idea that the government is mandating it
so he's gonna keep talking about you
know there's a black market for the
incandescent bulbs I just found out
about it yes he's got steamer trunks
full look that was announced in 2007
when they were gonna but then when they
raised the standard and every time Peter
would go to the store for like every
less they by the way pick up some of
those light bulbs because you don't know
how long we're gonna stockpiling them
how much do they cost in the black
market Dana you know we're gonna have to
save that for one of your supermarkets
that's right take a better guess
all right the president's rally now
behind us